fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
not a bad not a bad announcement
I'm getting I got to step my game up can
I hire you to be my [__] uh can I
tell you can I tell you I actually I
actually today I had a moment because
Sony and everyone everyone announced it
today so everyone I'm working with was
like
that's a really original way to announce
things and I thought brilliant and I
just hired this this woman who's [__]
amazing at social media and I thought I
wonder if I do do that as a company
because I I it's very easy for me to
think of ideas for you guys yeah sure
because it's not me yeah I would [__]
be all over it if you're that good I
mean I'm terrible at that stuff that
just watching that I'm like [__] up it's
so good dude I I feel like I wonder if I
sh like I'm in pretty good comment but I
think I might be a better marketer I
think you get a bowl I don't know but
you you could do marketing down the road
you don't do that now you don't need
anything it's like Adam 22. is he a
better porn star or better podcaster
very good question I've seen his porn
and he really lays it down
I don't know I I double dip I gotta step
my game up I have a guy
so it's not good enough to have a guy do
you it's not enough to have a guy no I
can walk you through everything I've
done seriously yeah it's not good enough
you need a shooter and you need an
editor and you need a producer full-time
full-time and then and then I just hired
one person strictly for social media who
knows it she [__] knows so I should
have somebody with a camera just around
coming up with ideas actually no just a
phone we shoot everything on phones
these days okay because everything's
[__] vertical so you just shoot
everything on [__] phones and so we I
have a cameraman who just takes a phone
around with him okay and and I know dude
it's so frustrating because before this
I bought a whole rig uh dlsrs or
whatever
you need the phone and so yeah and you
just have somebody follow you around and
you basically I come up with promos so
like so like uh one of my favorite ones
I did was uh Joe Coy was doing these
like uh tour buses no he goes hey
Brooklyn I love this promo and I loved
his promo he goes Brooklyn check this
out and he covered the camera with his
hands and then pull back and reveal sold
out Arena I was like that's [__] dope
and then I was like I was like how would
I do it and I'm sorry I was like Hey Hey
Joe Coy I've seen your promos man check
this out and I put my hands over the
camera and then I reveal and I'm totally
naked in an empty stadium and I cover my
dick and I'm like oh my God it went
wrong I was just trying to tell everyone
I'm gonna be in Boston next week right
it's it's one of my favorite
um that's so funny is is this you here
yeah go to me hitting the Home Run look
at me hitting the Home Run look like
John crock
look at this nice guy is there music
yeah we're recording oh we're recording
okay these kids are [__] ballers
they're from the high school yeah we
should we should start by saying that
you I was talking to Jesus your opener
said that he trained for this marathon
and then he looks over and you were
passing him and you ran 26 miles with no
problem in all fairness I think he had
to take a [__] 13 miles in but uh yeah
no I look at this this is at your high
school is that my high school taking BP
you're sneaky that's in Florida in
Florida right good good here we go boom
look at there we go look at these things
look at this look at this
oh [__] bat flip run the [__]
bases bring it in boys
and boys your future this is your
[__] future your boy went yard
[Music]
call my high school girlfriend yeah yeah
I was wait when's the last time you uh
hit balls when we did fully loaded last
year we were drunk and the team showed
up and the and they were like hey man we
heard you play baseball I said yeah and
they go you want to take some BP I never
say no to BP I have a hard time stopping
and so I go yeah and tells like I got a
hundred bucks since he doesn't hit it on
the infield and I was like I'm about to
take a towel's money yeah so I one
hopped it off the fence and their
pitcher said to me that's with no Pace I
went what he goes That's No Pace on it
that's me just like tossing it in I
thought I'd tab it to Pace that might
have gone yard on a wood bat so in my
head I'm like oh I know I can hand it
out with a steel bat I know I can with a
little Pace yeah and their their pitcher
uh that we just played for the Padres
the coach was used to play with Padres
he was putting Pace on it like a little
fast for me in my opinion you're scared
yeah and I had one that hit the fence in
left field and that's when I was like
I'm in I just need one pitch inside and
I pulled it hit it over the fence and
left field 310. and you wake up until
you sing to yourself always be promoting
always I used to I used to be really bad
I'm better at it now but I used to be
really bad at it where I'd have dates in
my head I have them memorized and so I'd
always be ready so if anything happened
if anything happened I could turn to the
camera and go rip a promo I'd have well
it was when I did uh when I did uh
the first tour I did body shots body
shots World Tour I could I just
everything rolled out I knew all my
dates because I pictured them on a map
and then uh and now I I've got so many
different things I'm promoting that I'll
tell you how it goes I got uh tops off
World Tour I've got uh my special Razzle
Dazzle coming out March 14th on Netflix
streaming right now you can check out my
machine movie coming out Memorial Day
Weekend only in theaters go to the
machine dot movie for a special
pre-taped event a live event that's
gonna happen Thursday in theaters and
then we just announced fully loaded we
got David tell Lewis Black
Mark Norman Shane Gillis Tiffany haddish
Tammy pescatelli Chad Daniels Jim Norton
uh uh [__] oh Ralph Barbosa I mean we
got it's [__] full it is the sickest
lineup I could have ever put together
and then we're doing two cities two
weeks in June and two weeks in July and
then I have the Australian tops off tour
I have so much [__] to promote I'm like
damn it yeah but that movie trailer like
sewed up you know when your buddy makes
a movie like okay have fun and then you
know it's like okay good luck with that
it's a legit have you seen the tree yeah
trailer like you want to see the trailer
no I repost hey everybody let's [__]
get this thing down
machine I don't know that story I'm
sorry I I know I know I know you told it
on Rogan by the way by the way right now
there's there's something 400 000 people
going please don't start this yeah yeah
I know myself I'll look it up also the
movie is about the story so guys look so
the machine story has 51 million views
that's
tell that story right yeah so yeah I
told that to Rogan on his podcast now
Rogan's beaks by the way I gotta I gotta
tell you I got to tell you bro hold on I
gotta say this and let Rogan's beak now
he's the one that came up with this plan
he changed my life because I told that
story on this podcast I then
he then said you need to tell that on
stage and I was not telling it on stage
and he was like you need to tell it on
stage and he said I was doing uh
Columbus Ohio the next weekend Columbus
funny bone
and he goes guys when you go to his show
from this point forward he's only going
to be to known as the machine and you
are to have him tell that story every
time he goes on stage you shout the
machine and I was like Joe and he's like
shout the machine until he tells it now
do you remember old school desk what
Ohio
old school death squad Ohio that was
like the the group of guys that were
like hardcore this is when Rogan was
doing out of his house they all showed
up to like almost every one of my shows
and the first show Thursday they were
like the machine and I was like guys I'm
not gonna tell it I appreciate what the
Joe said that but I have an act I have
to do I have an actor I have a closer
yeah and the one guy goes buddy it's
your story you have to tell it and he
was like we know it's going to be bad
but you got to tell it to make it good
right guys and they're all like yeah bro
come on and I was like I was like what
and then they were like we'll fake laugh
we promise I swear to God those were
those were like those guys like no
Susquehanna do you remember all those I
remember those before me no no no no no
oh maybe what maybe he was how long ago
it was it was like yeah that Squad crew
was red band and all those guys that was
when Joe started just first started his
podcast when Joe started it Joe Joe this
is a little uh history sticky subject at
times I was there I was there for one of
these conversations but death squad I
guess Brian had bought the death squad
name and he has started the death squad
Comedy Network on on podcasts but Joe
was Joe was podcast was the obviously
the biggest thing on Death Squad and it
was his only thing and Joe's group of
friends Opie from Opie and Anthony
Joe walked in with everyone like Tate
Fletcher and [__] and and uh Joey
Diaz and everyone and dopian from
opening Anthony said oh Joe brought on
his death squad so he started calling
him and his friends there's their death
squad right oh [__] the death squad's
here and so and so there was a moment
where I think they split and desk his
they had death squad East and death
squad West death squad West was Joe's
house and death squad East was Zeiss
house and one had a and one had a meow
like in the I mean like I'm a podcast
geek like I've listened to a lot of
[__] podcasts this goes really deep
but dude I was obsessed with Joe where's
the concert I was doing podcasts because
there was a moment where they split and
Brian took death squad and and tried to
make it a network but he missed by an
inch and it's not his fault no one was
doing it at the time but what he did was
he was putting everything on his RS I'm
by and Brian I apologize if I'm not if
I'm misrepresenting this because I don't
mean to but this is my recollection is
he had
everything on his RSS feed which is the
feed that for the network yeah for the
network and then he would release he did
Toms he did Joey's he did uh I think he
did one for triply and Ari and he was
releasing all of them on the RSS feed so
if he got backed up you may miss a week
because he needed to catch up for the
other guys and that's when Tom went off
and started your mom's house by himself
damn and so everyone was like was like
saw the value in owning their own RSS
feed and red Ben had all of them had he
and this is retrospect and once again I
apologize Brian if this isn't correct
had he started his their own RSS feeds
for everyone under the BET one banner
and created a product no one had that
Insight back then no one thought Joe was
selling [__] flashlights out of his
closet I remember I mean legit remember
you'd go there and he'd go have some of
my Alpha Brain he was a driver he would
do a podcast at the ice house a lot of
times too I did that a bunch of times
well that was the yeah that was the
death squad the death squad days and so
um I was uh I was fascinated all of it
and if had he had the insight to do what
like Chris Hardwick did where he just
because we just threw money at it was
like
let's hire some producers let's get
everyone their own things but let's put
it all under our Network Banner it's all
going on one website you guys own it all
and then Chris Hardwick turned around
and sold it to if I think he sold it to
Legendary made a lot of money and he
made it my six 16 million by the way
this was like this is the crazy thing
it's like now we all see that and and I
mean you look at thick boy Studios I
have birdie Boy Productions I just
bought a house we're building podcast
Studios out of there my problem is I
don't
I don't have
I don't care about this is gonna sound
[__] horrible but like I don't care
about starting a network so I don't want
to take Comics money and in order to
make a network and build it you got to
take a little bit a little get your beak
wet to to make it time for you and to
pay everyone out so I've had people want
to leave certain networks and come over
and have me produce it because I have a
great I have a great setup with a great
group of people I think we all used to
work together at one time that does my
on sales and it's been very beneficial
and I've learned a lot working with Tom
over at your mom's house and so I'm
trying to build mine and people go hey
can we just do ours out of yours and
then you can take your cut it's
complicated it gets complicated and I
don't want I don't want to I have enough
money and so I don't want to take money
from people but there's no way to run a
business without taking a little bit of
money you can't and so I just go [__] it
I'll just do me and my wife it's me my
wife I have two bears or I have a bird
cast uh your mom's or God damn it
pertcast wife of the party Uh
something's burning and open tabs and I
do them out of there and then we do all
our production for like our YouTube
channel out of there and and then all
the promos come out of there and then
what we're hoping to do is turn into a
media company where like when we were
talking earlier we're like
I would love the opportunity to help
Comics sell tickets it's something I've
dialed in on maybe maybe maybe too much
at times but like best at it I just I
come to you with a with any of that
stuff I just have I have I I come up
with an idea and I used to just go out
no one will do that now I know I can
afford it to make them and they don't
all hit some Miss but like the ones that
hit pop and you and then you make you
make a good amount of money selling
tickets yeah you get a return well
sometimes like what I'll find is I I go
to a town and like people they see me
like if I go somewhere I get recognized
a lot I know where you're going and it's
like the [__] you doing I don't know I'm
here son let me tell you I'm a fan what
are you doing here
Club let's [__] preach so I have a
theory never mind you're not successful
in this in comedy if anyone you go to
that City you're not doing your job if
any anytime you go to that City people
go when are you coming to Boston this is
what happens to me all day this is
something what do I do about that so I
learned this is how I learned you get a
wig
a wig I don't know if that's gonna work
see he has bad ideas
that's not a bad idea for a promotion
I'm not even [__] around yeah you're
in Boston and you go guys I was in
Boston my ticket sales were low and
people keep asking me about my shows and
then you put on a wig and you walk
around like hey man do you want Brian
Kyle's coming down you're like no but
he's in Tarzana next week okay exactly
because that's a greater all right fine
by the way you've got to make the
biggest people people uh kill themselves
by over analyzing just a thought because
once you turn on the camera you will
make it funny Once you turn on the
camera so here's how I changed
everything for me
uh because I I so I got offered to do
red rocks with Tim Jeffries at the time
I knew I was probably good for like
4 000 tickets in Denver how long ago is
this this is uh I know three years ago
four years ago three years ago I knew I
was I was good for like four thousand
tickets maybe five thousand tickets Red
Rock sells ten thousand
Jim Jefferies is having a baby and he
backs out he goes I can't it's our due
date weekend my wife wants me here I
need to be here and I totally understand
so now I know I'm out of the weekend Red
Rock calls and says hey man we we can't
fill in this short notice do you want
the weekend by yourself and now I know I
can't fail because they already know
that I wasn't supposed to sell it but
now I get the opportunity to see if I
can move 10 000 tickets in a market so I
said to myself I I will only succeed not
if I sell it out but if I go into this
venue do my show and then I spent I was
taking George around Boulder I wanted to
go to Boulder if I if I am around that
City and no one says to me what are you
doing here right and what was crazy is
we spent we went to Colorado State
University Colorado Boulder and then we
hung out in Evergreen where we were
staying not doing stand-up you were just
there well I I stayed the extra night
and watched Jimmy Buffett uh I did the
show well I ended up selling it out but
I did the show and I just promoted the
[__] out of it and Comics hit me up and
they're like dude we get it you're doing
[__] Red Rocks and I go no it's not
about you you're not who I give a [__]
about because you are never gonna buy a
ticket to my show because you're my
friend you're in the business you're in
the business what I care about is I will
never get upset if I found out that my
favorite comic or my favorite artist is
coming to my town if we'll go post every
single day from this point until they're
showing five months from now not once
will I see that post and go enough Wilco
because I want to be reminded that that
show is then right I want to go oh
that's right Wilkos and [__] sure
because yeah because we're so insecure
about that yeah you're also because
you're like I retweeted it or I made a
video about it oh my god dude the people
getting upset about that are the people
not going to the show the people going
to the show how many times you bought
concert tickets and then forgot and
missed the concert you're like [__] why
didn't I wish I I've never done that but
I like where you're going I've done that
I've done that twice I've never done it
I feel you I've done that it could
happen yeah so then I went to do Red
Rocks I did promos out the ass I was
always doing promos on your own social
media on my own social media I was I was
doing them all by myself at the time and
and I had I had I was in Serbia shooting
the movie and I had blown out my elbow
doing my own stunts I had to go in for
surgery and they were like what song do
you want to get put down to and I said
this video is great and I said [__] this
I go
credence
and and don't count me backwards I'm
going to do a promo with my phone and
when I go out I want the phone to drop
and I'm going to keep doing the promo
until it drops and that'll be my promo I
don't know and so I I was going into
surgery they're playing CCR and I'm
going uh and they're like you're go
you're going under and I go I go yeah I
am hey guys what's if I'm going under
and I'm scared I'm nervous and I don't
want to make if I don't make it out of
this I want you to know one thing I will
be at Red Rocks and I'm do and you hear
everyone in the room laughing and I go
Jimmy Buffett's there the next night my
car and my anesthesiologist is like wait
I want to see Jimmy Buffett I go you
want to come to the show and he's like
yeah I go I will see you're there and I
dropped the phone and that's my promo
and it sold out Red Rocks for me and
when I went through Evergreen anyone
said you gotta [__] have I gotta
figure it out let me tell you
[Music]
the real game changer is we do we do uh
sober October the first year yeah and
and
okay
and so and so I tell and it did really
well and I noticed that it moved tickets
for the rest of the Tour all of a sudden
everything cleaned up and everything
everything out of the show and I was
like wow it's crazy so I said to Joe and
Tom and Ari I said hey maybe we should
next year instead of a challenge let's
do hip-hop dance we'll each learning
hip-hop dance and then we'll learn it
throughout the month we'll practice you
burn calories Joe's not entertaining
that
you have no idea how quick Joe shot it
down no I do I'm not doing that no I do
not doing that it's out of my comfort
zone
October if that's what you're doing
I'm not we're all like okay we'll just
stop yeah stupid idea I'm just kidding
yeah so we all put on chest straps and
then almost proceeded to murder each
other trying to out calorie each other
for the day but in doing so I still
fought hip-hop dance was a good idea I
like it so I took so I took hip-hop
dance lessons what we were just talking
about this last podcast yeah girl put a
[__] production like the Jabberwocky
oh dude well now I put on I put on a I
took lessons for 1200 with this woman
this is my promo of me going under I
need her number I can't believe it
you're in a good place
surgery right now
I just for playing Cruise survival
perfect way to go under I have a great
team around me I have a great team
around me
but what I want to tell you
you're all hide
the night before the night after oh
I have invited my anesthesiologists
[Laughter]
wow let's take a little break from
chatting with birdie boy the machine his
movie comes out I'm sorry his special
drops I think this week as well right
Bert's special drops on Netflix this
week so go check out one of the best in
the biz it's Bert Kreischer and his
special drops this mother Trucking week
that's right it's Razzle Dazzle it drops
on Netflix March 14th so make sure you
go check out our boy Bert Chrysler
special on Netflix available March 14th
uh if you want to see your boy I'm on
tour Tacoma Washington Tacoma comedy
club one of my faves March 23rd to the
25th Atlanta Georgia is April 13th
through the 15th and then we just added
La Jolla comic store that's La Jolla
right side San Diego at one of my
favorite venues of all time it's The
Comedy Store in La Jolla that is June
2nd through the 4th and then tickets for
my Europe tour are available right now
pre-sale is over so now you can get Joe
tickets Belfast June 15th Glasgow June
17th Manchester June 18th London June
22nd Cardiff June 23rd Dublin June 25th
get your tickets at fatkz.com or
thickboy.com also thick boy St Patty
days merch is available right now at
thickboy.com and go see my brother from
a definitely very older mother my boy
Brian Collins back in New York at West
Nyack Levity Live that's March 16th
through the 18th and then he's in
Magooby's great Club in Maryland right
outside Baltimore that's Friday March
31st through Saturday April 1st so go
get your tickets see Brian town in West
Nyack New York and Baltimore Maryland
tickets at fatkz.com
all right let's get into it this episode
of the finally kid with Bert Chrysler is
brought to you by Helix mattresses Helix
mattresses are fantastic I've had the
Masters for over five years now my kid
sleeps on it my seven-year-old sleeps on
it we're talking about premium
mattresses shipped straight to your door
free of charge Helix knows there's no
better way to test out a new mattress
than my sleeping on it it's the only way
to know all right that's why they offer
100 night risk-free trial all right they
have a 10 to 15 year warranty so try it
out all right for the new Helix mattress
models with a more responsive foam to
cradle your body if you have that thick
body sleep on your side sleep on your
stomach Helix all you gotta do I did it
you take the Helix sleep quiz and I was
matched with the perfect model for my
thick body all right I want something
that felt kind of firm all right and I
sleep on my side so they gave me the
perfect mattress not only is the
mattress the best I've slept on but the
setup was fast super easy Helix
mattresses are delivered in a box
straight to your door for free they're
American made right and like I told you
they come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
depending on the model that you get but
don't take my word for it all right
Helix has been awarded the number one
mattress picked by GQ and Wired Magazine
it's even recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving your sleep so there you have
you want to sleep better get you some
Helix Helix is offering you guys up to
20 off all mattress orders and free two
pillows for the listeners of fire on the
kid go to helixsleep.com fighter this is
the best offer yet and it won't last
long with Helix better sleep starts now
helixsleep.com fighter I'll tell you
what once a month it's like Christmas
that's right one of the best days of the
month is when my box of Awesomeness
arrives at my doorstep talking about
best spoke post one of the coolest
things about best spoke every unique
item is hand curated from a small
business that you probably would never
have heard of otherwise you're getting
cool unique stuff from cozy Essentials
to travel with all right they have
cocktail kicks box of awesome has
everything you need this month to get
started take a quiz at boxofawesome.com
that's box of awesome.com your answer
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued around 70
bucks all right but you only pay a
fraction of that price and you get
really cool unique stuff from Small Time
businesses plus with each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses
ninety percent of everything that comes
in your box of Awesomeness from a small
up and coming brand it's free to sign up
you can skip a month or cancel anytime
you want so if you want a whole lot of
Awesomeness get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at
boxofawesome.com enter the code fighter
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code Fighter for twinks off your first
box box of awesome.com code fighter
awesome so wait by the way I've been
talking about nothing but doing hip-hop
dance because I saw Magic Mike and I
want
so I pay this lady d Snyder 1200 and I
said can you teach me how to dance and
she says uh just if you type Dance I'm
sure it comes up and so there you go uh
oh no that's the yeah I think that's it
yeah yeah that's it good and so
it's post Malone
is that is that your instructor that's
my instructor she's awesome
you wanna just play and then yeah yeah
you're oil up but yeah oh I'm sweaty
I've been doing dancing all day you're
actually good though how did you get
away with using the music
[__] them but you're good
a week
did you have to pay for the song no no
and now look at this I remember this of
course
by the way every one of these sold out
every one of them added a show and all
the show added ones added another shows
that I had come back for so so now
here's the here's see Tom's up there
here's the rub here's the rub so sigura
sees that and everyone's like Bert can
actually dance and he gets a genuinely
offended and competitive who thinks he
decides better and he's a good dancer
but he ends up spending like 60 Grand on
his hip-hop video his is soda
Tom if someone has one motto it's throw
money at it yeah if it's one motto throw
money at it and Thomas money yeah want
to lose weight throw money at it he's
lost money I mean lost weight yeah yeah
yeah yeah crazy a lot of people in
Hollywood are losing weight these days
[Laughter]
by the way I got a same doctor
a little trt knows you're wrong
how do you feel about that testosterone
I love it this is a sixth podcast of the
day look at his [__] energy
dude I'm [__] [__] flying I got
these vitamins I got this [__] but
you wake up your dicks rock hard oh I
[__] a pillow tonight so so Tom does
this and I tell him I go throw your
dates on the end yeah because it'll sell
and he's all right I gotta do Australia
and he had canceled Australia so many
times he threw this on Australia his day
sold out they added shows so then all of
a sudden I'm like that's the first timer
I'm like I'm on to something so Bert is
this not from your play Tom is this not
from your Netflix specials this is from
yourself
so how much do you what do you give how
much credit do you give to your Netflix
specials versus what you do on social
media so Netflix so it's twofold I I I
call this the uh
for lack of better words the the Bill
Burr effect right so Bill Burr had his
Philly rant which was [__] genius yes
[__] genius but that's not all he
does he has a great body of work behind
him to support him the same thing
happens to Jim Jeffries Jim Jefferies
got punched in the head of the comedy
store in London and it went viral on
MySpace I'm saying they have a catalog
but you have a catalog You could argue
You could argue the same thing happened
with Rogan he stood up for comics
with the Carlos Mencia thing he goes
[__] viral and people see the Joe
show and all his stand-up and all this
and they go wow this guy's [__] it's
a snowball it's a snowball but you need
the spark the spark is the thing so what
I try to do is create little Sparks
throughout to drive them to the content
because then they go oh well two bears
is funny Kool-Aid Jennifer Aniston
Hitler's teacup uh [__] oh this this
is the hardest bird to ever laugh this
is the five hardest person this is is a
long one and then and then and then the
Netflix specials I got five four and F
four on Netflix right now and so
so these are the Sparks you got to
create just to keep people remembering
and and it's not just I mean I always
it's fine to be like hey guys I I got a
Netflix special but you could just if
you take a second in your day and just
go what can I do to a little extra to
just Razzle Dazzle it you know to just
to put a little judge on it yes and
that's and but when Tom did that he took
it another level Toms is like an MTV
Unplugged it's the way he tricks you
that he can't dance is he has a lot of
visual effects and he has all these
backup dancers yeah
this is yeah Tom take another level
this is awful
I'll tell you the real funny part of
this story in a second
that girl looks like a little Uzi vert
she's very cute that black girl yeah
definitely
Steven Seagal's inspiration I think how
long this would take to learn it took a
whole day and I can tell you how many
calories he burned because it was during
sober October when the chapter but see
Tom's athletic too Tom's Tom's not
moving like Bert though no no no no oh
he made them all fat
[Laughter]
yes he can
yeah I take that back that's the only
Dance part yes
you're welcome
amazing it was uh I mean that makes me
this is so inspiring to me because I
feel like I've been lazy as [__] that's
a different level like that would be
like watching basketball when we don't
play basketball yeah but you're watching
LeBron being like but you can do it you
can do all this you just got to find
your it's it's I got lucky in that I was
doing it I was doing it pretty early so
like
even my bad ones people are like yeah
they tried you know like I've but yeah
but that's great dude that's also the
best at it he's great but he works
really hard and he's Relentless he's
like you what you you wake up in the
morning and that's your mind
was destroying that tiger thing and you
do it while you're drinking that much
whiskey which is [__] incredible
well I treat myself you've earned it I
have earned it I feel like I have it if
we celebrate every Victory this gives
you energy and it makes you euphoria
work I don't have I guess huberman said
something about it uh Andrew yeah or
someone did about like how yeah it booze
Works differently for different people
and for some people it gets them up if
you're of I guess northern European
descent that's me okay so those so
there's something yeah there's a segment
of the population when they get drunk
see I get sick I don't get drunk I get
sick
I'm not kidding I get sick people gay
yes hey you're bullies hey you alcohol
bullies you guys are a couple I'm gonna
drink with Birds because I get like I
have that and I'm [__] for the rest of
the day for real yes but now you have a
chemistry that makes you feel real it
makes you feel your forearm you don't
give thoughts of fancy
guys
it's so fun I hear let me have some nope
my heart skips a beat it's like a first
kiss for me I feel like when you have a
drink it's like I don't give first
kisses but I get cocktails yeah I did a
rant about that I watched you it was so
great because you were like there's
nothing I enjoy more when somebody says
do you want to have a drink and you're
like you know I do yeah and I'd like to
have another drink and it just gets
better when Rogue and they're like we
gotta talk to Bert to stop like how dare
you what are you trying to do I don't
think do you want to take Superman's
cape [__]
I think Joe's always got Joe just I I
think what's the best for you that's why
he wants the best for you to be good for
it he's a party pooper though great he's
a real he also no Joe it's not we're
killing him Joe's the opposite he just
wants to live forever so Joe's a party
pooper he wants to live forever so he'll
be like like I had a conversation the
other day he goes I never eat bread I
was like so bread because I never eat
bread I don't eat wheat he goes rarely
once in a blue moon I'll have a little
Posse so [__] intense right yeah I'll
have a little pasta well we do the
companion I go hey dude what are you
getting ready for yeah
you're enormous yeah he's Jack ready for
the I don't know about it
25 years ago we're doing [__] news
radio and we're playing as brothers and
Joe's sitting there he's standing there
like this and the veins and the Paula
goes look at him it's like a little ball
of hate just a ball of hate and veins
right and he's just he's just and then
Nick goes Nick just goes Joe when you
don't work out and before he got out Joe
because I I never not there's never a
day I don't work out there's never a day
what do you ask me he's well he was so
intense we're like Jesus okay time every
day I'll tell you what the best advice
Joe gave me did you know you were there
too but Joe told me long before during
the pandemic when Joe was going through
all that they're trying to cancel him
because the n-word all that stuff I
can't we talked every day and he's like
I'm like you could he's like I've never
been better man I'm like what the [__]
is wrong with you he goes shrooms yeah I
micro those shrooms he's like you gotta
start doing I'm like dude you had your
mind hung up the phone didn't talk to
him about it ever again and then we were
doing the companion you guys are like
yeah do the shrooms you gotta do shrooms
my God it's fantastic it's just takes
you do it no I I have I do them every
day yeah every day because I have a chip
this big on my [__] shoulder the the
shroom we had a hard time of it the
shrooms bring it down here yeah the
chips are they kind of focus they focus
everything can I tell you can I tell you
can I tell you a business model you
should do is leaning did you ever hear
MC Hammer used to sell shirts at his
show that said MC Hammer sucks no oh
yeah and then he'd make more money on
those shirts you know he used to be my
manager MC Hammer was your manager yeah
when I was fighter when I was fighting
he's my manager in the UFC are you
[__] serious I've been on Jets within
planes are you serious if you can get
him and I know him well yeah I'm on your
podcast the best stories you've ever
heard about death Pro he was with Tupac
the night he died about him being broke
I go hey man when you were like broke he
was broke weren't you Bank reviews Baba
I was empty Hammer broke I still had
four houses yeah I was like oh he's
still he's I [__] and a good man I
think I worked with him you know he's
brilliant you know so he invested in
Uber and Facebook like 10 years ago he's
no stupid rich I I love the nicest guy I
know I I love when you hear that I I
worked with I've worked with weird
celebrities at times that you go like I
can't believe I met this guy so like I'm
Tom Sizemore I didn't work with him but
I met him on Larchmont and I think he
was high he was trying to figure out a
uh uh a [__] coin-operated uh parking
machine
and I was like I was like Hey and he
just turned around he's like oh you're
[__] hilarious and I was like oh
thanks man well I got a story about
Sizemore we had the same agent bring up
top my Asian because my Asian calls me
up and goes you know he's unhirable and
uh I told him I told him to talk no he
goes I told him to talk to you so I so
I'm like oh easy woman he died right
yeah yeah that's what we're talking
about him yeah I don't know who we're
talking about
so yeah
in my head I was like you're gonna find
out that he's dead
he was such a good actor Saving Private
Ryan [__] Black Hawk Down amazing but
he had he got to a point where my agent
said look he's unhireable because of the
drugs and he goes can you talk to him I
go where's the money about drugs and why
would you want me to talk to him so long
story short I'm on the phone with him
apparently his brain aneurysm happened
at CrossFit
all right well he was a really good guy
I'm kidding and I made that up I don't
know if he kills people no wow he had a
problem with the drugs and he never his
eyes aren't lazy at all uh what were you
saying to be he just had a problem he
could never kick it you know she is you
know Heidi flies of course the Madam how
dare you thank you I'd reached out to
her uh yeah he's killing it yeah well
you know your assistant's a good looking
kid he's gorgeous he looks like Jon Snow
Brian I will give you a thousand dollars
if you know what that shirt is from what
movie Callahan brake pads Sandusky who
was in it uh that might be Talladega
Nights oh hold on hold on hold on [__]
you I'm gonna give you a five more
chances yeah Callahan brake pads
thousand dollars
um I'll I'll cash that be a thousand
dollars right now you get that right
really why boy because I'm old and I
wouldn't know it you should know it okay
let me tell you a story about it let me
tell you let me tell you let me tell you
a story about Callahan break back okay
yeah great company great great Hometown
company out of Sandusky Ohio yes the dad
uh decides to double down and and double
down on his brake pads and reinvest in
the company reinvest it himself and he
falls in love falls in love with a woman
a little bit younger not a ton younger
than her but gorgeous you some people
will call her a 10. and I say 11. I I
would say exactly a ten yes and and and
uh and then
his son graduates College yes his son
graduates College upon his graduation
his dad says buddy you got what it takes
to be part of Callahan Auto Parts it's a
great story it brings them in a movie
there's a movie yeah brings him in and
at the wedding documentary dad has a
heart attack and the sun along with his
side
I'm sorry guys wait wait don't leave so
Poland all right keep going let me give
him one clue Sidekick is David Spade why
would you say
Chris Farley movie yeah it is and you
say black sheep I'm gonna eat my it's
not Black Sheep it's not so much here
more here yeah
he was Eminem they have they have they
have hard shell casings what's the movie
did it come out as a book first homie
boy
are you serious I've never seen [__]
epic [__] epic because you want him
to make good promos without a wish Jesus
Christ I gotta do I'm gonna do a wig I
got this that's what I got Tom well the
greatest movies of all time never saw it
David Spade yeah how great it's [__]
David Spade
yeah I didn't realize how talented he
was till I did that uh his Comedy
Central show I did like several times
and you watch them host and I'm like oh
yeah he's from the Saturday Night Live
days when it [__] counted oh yeah
he's so talented and he's the sweetest
he's so nice man he's uh he's I love
that he voice texts you when you like
when you every time voice text and it's
and it's cool because it's like Chrysler
Spade yeah and it's like he's in
character yeah the only one better than
him in my opinion was Norm because Norm
Macdonald there was always a joke to it
it so like for my last special it was
supposed to air on March 17th stay at
home orders started March 13th and I had
a big show planned at the I think I both
you guys booked uh for a call and stick
to work show in the in the morning on
same time you're supposed to be here St
Patty's Day on the 17th but you know
stay at home Motors no one's allowed to
leave their house
March 17th at nine in the morning I got
a text from Norm where are you
I said I'm in my house and he goes are
we doing this show or not
I said Norma's stay-at-home orders he's
like oops he was the best man do you
ever see his that clip with him and Bob
Saget when Bob Saget was talking about
Dean Martin no back in the day can you
bring that up please that's all I'm
gonna say nothing was sacred to Norm
Macdonald
he ends the podcast he did a podcast
with Bob Saget Bob Saget starts telling
a very heartfelt story about
about
about this is is this the one it's got
to be yeah it talks about Dean Martin
Dean Martin that hamburger Hamlet you
know everything that's what I meant
that's where I saw him
yeah we must have talked about it I
don't know well you know it was me and
hamburger and I walked in there and he
had lost his son and he was sitting
there and he and he looked up and it was
it was nice and I just went I found your
son
[Laughter]
that laugh that [__] laughs
[Music]
dude I found you a song
Bob because I got a flight Bob's in
first class and Brian's going back to
coach it was hey Brian everyone goes
I've won no no he goes where are you
sitting I go eight a he goes in coach I
go yeah he goes then I won huh
how did you get canceled I go yeah he
goes for your comedy
coach who I've won that's crazy both
those guys are dead
[__] sucks that Norm laughed that
Norm laugh when he just gets the joke I
bet him one time one time in The Comedy
Store and he goes hey hey uh can I talk
to you what's up man yeah you you used
to fight right yeah he goes well you
know the the betting I go what about it
because you got the insight to that
stuff
I don't think if I wanted to give him
something I don't think so he was ah
okay you better go yeah yeah we're
talking fighting yeah backstage for
right before I go on stage and then he
walks off and Samuels dude he's a
degenerate Gambler Artie Lang tells a
story about how he goes hey come over
you want to see something all right he
goes I guess what he goes come over and
he has a shoe box full it's a hundred
grand in cash this is back in 90. yeah
and he goes and he had to go give it to
his bookie you know he was a serious
gambler back to Spades of Spades these
voicemails and Spade whenever I'm doing
like shopping friends at Icehouse or
improv Comics or whatever Spade's my
first call he always shows up he always
does it I go Spade Ice House Is Back you
in voicemail shop Spade here he goes but
it's not in LA right
just that nothing and I go yeah but it's
ice house it's not too bad it's not La
though I'm like okay let's get him on
the podcast he's crazy
[__] gold when I [__] the bed with
Adam Sandler I had to shoot a bit of
Adam I did I did uh a podcast with him
like uh during what during Adam Sandler
it was it was during covid and it was
called comedy gives back and I I [__]
up I I [__] up massively oh was that
one of those streaming shows I think you
did a podcast with them on your on
streaming show and I didn't let him talk
which is very me I didn't let him talk
and I [__]
I I said I was asking if he had Netflix
no I wasn't I wasn't he is Netflix no
yeah I know now I know now I asked him I
told him I liked his movie uh precious
gems holy [__] and I told him I just
shown uh the movie Happy Madison to my
daughters and they loved it they did a
great job on Happy Madison
nope sounds over whoa sounds sober the
look on Whitney Cummings face when I got
done the interview was like she watched
someone almost get attacked by a shark
but they rode it to the boat and she was
like what was that and I was like and I
thought I killed it and I was like it's
[__] good right she's like yeah and I
got my car and Big Jay oakerson called
me and he goes he goes oh bro [__]
Chandler epic and I go I go is it that
good and he goes good he goes I'm giving
you a heads up we're legionist gangsters
going on next and we are about to trash
you and I said for what and he goes you
asked Adam Sandler if he had Netflix I
go that's a good question I was
promoting my Spanish only goes bro he
has a 300 million dollar deal he
definitely has [__] Netflix he goes
you call this movie prices gems like oh
that's not the name of his movie he goes
you called the other one happy Madison
he goes we're trashing you right now I
gotta go bye I'm click and hung up and I
went oh my God got to my house I'm
[__] panicking going I love Adam
Sandler I hope like I told him I go Adam
you'll hear a cool story and he was like
ah yeah he's in college in college you
were in powwow at my school of Florida
State in 1997 he was like yeah and I go
and then the girl there was a girl that
I was dating and then she went home with
you and then she called me and they
smoked pie with you and I and then she
told me to come over and I never came
over but I couldn't come over wouldn't
that be crazy and he was like okay I go
Adam Adam you can I tell you about the
time again I mean it was so [__] bad
oh my God and then Spade leaves me a
voice Max bro the [__] Sandler
interview epic and that's it
no no no no he was like he wrote back
he's like or step back he goes
Sandler watches especially thinks you're
hilarious uh uh he thought it was
hilarious he's like you are Farley in
those interviews
he goes Paul McCartney do you remember
when you wrote it yeah that's right
that's right because you are thank God I
was like they wrote that off of you yeah
he did that that was awesome that was
awesome
and so and then I ended up doing a
dealer with Happy Madison to make a
movie so they were cool he he did this
movie no no no another one
all right
I never thought I'd ever want to make a
movie in my entire [__] life I had no
that's a lot of work because you and Tom
are opposite because Tom I know has been
offered movie roles and turned it down
oh yes the guy that runs the carnival
and tries to molest kids no no no he got
offered a big time role yeah no he big
time well he did he's like you don't
want to be that famous yeah they don't
make sense
a girl said this yes
um we'll talk after okay if anybody's
taking a lot of real small time rolls
like the step brother of Mark Wahlberg
in in uh and adopt these kids or
whatever that movie was he's taking a
lot of [__] roles he was good I saw him
in something he was really good what
adopt those kids adopt those kids or
something remember when the white people
needed kids
yeah yeah I think that's it and Tom's in
that and he worked like for a month for
30 grand and I was like and I was like
why would you [__] do that it's the
worst you wait around all day that I've
never done go through his IMD let's see
all the movies he's done and then tell
me the ones
he's in pre-production on a new movie
called clinch the opening act cabin with
you okay
instant family instant family instant
family
yeah that's with Will Ferrell too no
it's with Mark Wahlberg adopt those kids
though something it's called something
and then they died Tom's beard and he
looks absolutely ridiculous
no no actually Tom is in the trailer no
yeah yeah Tom's in the trailer he's like
yeah good luck with that
it's a it's a really like he really
Nails this role you know who can
actually act her ass off is Bill Burr
yeah in Staten Island he's crushing it
man uh Pete Davidson was pretty [__]
great in that too yeah fun watching him
I don't think he's gonna be yeah I do
he's such a good guy he's a great guy
yeah he's a great guy and he's doing
[__] phenomenal they don't think he's
gonna be in this trailer maybe but just
see a picture of him
wow there
hi
do you that's five years ago yeah he's
ages
he's got a lot skinnier though yeah you
guys are on the Hollywood Diet huh both
of you no I do hard work
dude I just would can I tell you I just
want to get back to regular fat like
right now I'm right now I'm like I'm
like oh fat like I don't know about that
all right by performing my shirt off and
trust me
261 yesterday you weigh 261. yeah I was
257.50
[__]
[__] animals baby how long you been on
testosterone one day
[Laughter]
next week three times a week uh 250
milligrams
like you do the whole vial oh I was like
holy [__] but I'm getting I'm kidding
yeah [__] I'll be honest about
everything but two 25 milligrams 25
oh
the needle 25 on the needle I'm the only
guy not on testosterone and so and so so
I I went to my car this is I I am uh I
am
I don't care full disclosure full
disclosure because if it works for me I
wanted to work for you yeah uh I went to
my cardiologist my last visit and I I
have been on the road pretty
aggressively and the most aggressive the
most aggressive I've ever been and I and
my blood pressure was perfect which is
never the case it's actually High
usually High my blood pressure was
perfect my cholesterol is perfect they
had upped my I'm burning five years your
cholesterol is perfect my cholesterol is
well I'm on 20 milligrams of statins
okay so which is a lot and he said uh
with that dosage I'm a little concerned
for your liver we're going to do some
liver tests on you just to check your
Alta act or ASD whatever it's called
and he goes and he goes and if it's high
can I suggest is my cardiologist saying
this not [__] anyone else he goes I
suggest
testosterone I'm going to check your
testosterone levels too I'll see if
they're low yes I said really I said
well I I've a buddy on testosterone I
have a couple buddies on testosterone
all my buddies
why that and he goes well if you're if
your levels are high the testosterone
will help heal your liver so it'll help
unclog it and so he said and there's so
you should check with one of these
there's a lot of places nearly named a
bunch of places in LA and I knew a guy
previously that uh I'm always hasn't
seen anyone's name but and and I don't I
mean still because I don't have control
of editing his name out but it's the
same guy that gave me uh uh intravenous
stem cells and stem cells in my elbow
that I trust I know the guy and I want
to promote his business and I hope I do
but I don't I'm always sketchy about
saying [__] like this you know but
because no one's ever honest with it and
um
so I called him I said I just got my
blood panel back can I get send it to
you and you tell me what you think he
sent me over to his the head person over
there and they were like
and they had worked with me before I'd
gotten stem cells introduced in stem
cells and she goes can I do a blood
panel on you and I said not now she goes
why not I said well I'm partying a lot
she goes if you give me a blood panel I
can help fix that and I was like yeah no
no I didn't understand her so we did a
meeting and she said you told me your
lifestyle my thing is to crack your
lifestyle just to get you on stuff
that'll help fix your lifestyle we want
to uh get your own testosterone that
will help prepare your liver so let's do
that and the other was damaged no well I
have a fatty liver everyone is a [__]
fatty liver like anyone you don't think
yours is extra fatty no no it's never my
never my numbers have never been up
they've always been in the in the range
and so I was always like I'm good I'm
good I'm good not realizing probably
that there are times when I'm partying
hard that it's out of range you know but
this time I was definitely partying hard
and it was out of the range it was the
first time it ever happened I'm talking
like I went to Rams games I went to my
cardiologist the next day in the range
totally fine in the green but you had
you go to a Cardiologist because your
heart's been a problem in the past nope
I go to cardiologists every six months
because
strokes and heart attack running my
family okay so I get EKGs I do CT scans
I do cardi scans oh wow I do everything
and I'm I'm at below 15 in both carotid
arteries zero for calcification for
calcification zero percent of my heart
and my blood pressure is in check my
cholesterol I would like to lower my
cholesterol medication to 10 milligrams
because it does tax your that is the
medication taxes your liver which is
fine if you don't party and you don't
drink but if you part in your drink it
shows up and that's where now party I've
heard guys that were on the road with
him you guys can figure out who it is
they're saying Bert will party all
through the night and then wake up and
before as he wakes the other guys up the
features you know and he'll have a
[__] Mimosa or [__] you can drink
you can go hey we gotta go work out
we're like what the [__] I'm trying to
recover you can work you can drink could
you drink that bottle of whiskey and you
would be fine uh not fine no I'm saying
but the next morning yeah
I used to work out I used to jog on the
treadmill with a box of wine that was
like yeah there's red wine stains all
over this [__] treadmill I used to
leave a box of wine up there and I drink
with a box of wine and run it was my one
of my favorite things to do because you
have energy when you drink I guess I
guess so how much do you think on in a
week how many drinks do you think you
have really good about myself Pete would
know Pete how many drinks do you have
and don't say it just don't say it so
let's just shut up hey hold on
hey more than 10 blink oh 10 drinks in a
week yeah yeah buddy yeah buddy buddy I
use I use low I don't I use I use so so
I have lately lately I've been leaning
into beer Bud light's a little bit more
because I've been hanging out with Shane
Gillis and he's a Bud Light guy he's so
American
um and but I my other drink is tequila
soda and lime I get key lime juice and
uh and I drink them out of Starbucks
venti cups
and so okay it says we grab them when
we're on the road and so that's it
usually my my my my my level and it's
gonna sound really high but I don't know
any other way than to [__] be super
honest about my drinking because it
[__] you'll get caught as a liar if
you're an alcoholic you'll get caught
yeah I mean I haven't yet but yeah the
well I did it when we did sober October
Rogan's like how much do you drink and I
had a choice oh you were honest I was
like I was like do I tell them the truth
or do I lie because I could lie I could
lie at the time I mean it still is but
at the time and while I'm doing it I
know this is the biggest podcast in the
world
and you get found out you get found out
and so I said uh I have like nine drinks
tonight and he was like well you'll find
whatever the [__] I said but I said not
let's just say nine drinks a night
that's a fair guess how many bottles is
that hold on yeah it gets better and you
know Joe you know Joe with his uh his
little like uncarronized
body you see wait hold on oh and you
almost go like you almost see him write
you off in his eyes like I can't [__]
with people that drink like that because
you're gonna die anyway yeah
it's like your dog you're like oh my dog
doesn't have much yeah I gotta start
detaching and Tom seguro starts laughing
and he goes they're doubles
Joe goes what so that's 18. there's a
hatred 18 drinks a night 18 drinks a
night he has 18 drinks a night and you
watch Joe just so then Joe said we
should go sober we should do sober
October that's why he did this and then
yeah of course they need to help you and
then well then he said he goes hey man
you may need medical help to get off
this and I was like by the way there's a
lot of times I don't drink so I'm
sitting there going I definitely don't
need medical help and he's like yes and
then leaving the old school Rogan one on
in in the old school right here yeah
yeah la yeah the one in L.A yeah it was
no no no before before the one before
the the big one before the big one the
one before that oh okay I'm in the
office building yes
or leaving the energy is shifted we've
decided to do sober October Joe is now
sullen and as I walk out of the door he
goes hey man
if you don't want to do this we don't
have to do this and he hugs me he goes
and I'm like oh this isn't fun anymore I
laid in bed I laid him back and I went I
just [__] up my career so bad I told
everyone how much I drink I should have
never done that so never [__] that's
true because now it's gonna be now it's
gonna look sad when I drink on stage if
I have a drink on stage you're gonna be
like no you're such a happy drunk yeah
and so and so I did sober October I did
not I did not do the detox I just
stopped drinking yeah October 1st how
many put it so so how many bottles so
it's it's a bottle of tequila that's
sketchy but I could but I can tell you
this is this
I
Bert Chrysler can drink one bottle of
wine a night and maybe a glass after
yeah and be 100 ready for anything
tomorrow throws me including a 90-minute
workout that's like 30 minutes on on
cardio an hour of weight lifting why
this different I can do that I can drink
a bottle so that was my key when we were
doing the movie
um I'm talking about tequila can you
drink a bottle of tequila it goes down
so sadly my tequila is so my recovery on
tequila is so much better than all mine
with my whoops it's not all that Sugar
it was in the 80 and so I was like
tequila is my thing I Can Drink To Kill
and just wake the [__] up whiskey [__]
me up a little bit I don't know if
there's sugars or it's aged or there's
some sugar there's something like
carcinogen I mean one is one is like you
know from a cactus the other's wheat and
that's full of impurities and stuff like
that like tequila is pretty pure well
vodka vodka was my jam for a long time
and and I would drink Tito's and when
Tom and I did the weight loss challenge
I drank Tito's and I was completely fine
and then there's a part of me that
sounds really [__] but there's a part
of me that I'd promoted to Tito so much
and I never got any love back from them
I was just gonna say how do you not have
a deal that's crazy okay how do you not
have a whiskey or a tequila I don't know
wait wait so so
respectfully thank you wait let me ask
you this um
do you care about like not a whiskey guy
though I like your whiskey I'm not a
whiskey guy it's like it's like if
you're gonna make an alcohol what are
you gonna make I don't know I mean like
the truth is I I enjoy whiskey but like
money's in tequila for your bird uh I
don't know but you don't you don't care
about the taste Bert the taste of what
of whatever it is it's not the taste
you're just drinking because you like
this yeah I don't know wait hold on no I
don't drink the taste you don't drink
you don't drink you don't sip tequila I
don't [__] for the eye contact yeah I
[__] for the [__] I [__] with a gum I
want the [__] orgasm I want how to
connect with her I just want
just whatever okay
yeah I don't drink I don't drink [__]
you know taste
[__]
[__] would you
surprise the opposite I know I like I
like sipping tequila God damn it I'm
like well what is this
Asian Cherry cast no oh [__] can I get
another one yeah no way yeah you can
have as much as you want
uh incredible the uh no I don't I
definitely don't uh
I don't drink for the taste uh I don't
mind like
I mean I can get super cute little face
hey Pete can you grab me another ice
cube out of the fridge yeah I mean the
fridge is a bunch of ice cubes um I
enjoy
I enjoy moments I enjoy moments and I
think alcohol gets you to that moment
because it lowers everyone's guard and
it brings you closer when you say to
each other
um like the other morning at the airport
we're at the airport and we came up with
a TV show for uh I came up with a TV
show idea and uh everyone liked it and
everyone got excited so a whole team
traveling my trainer my everyone and no
one wanted to drink and I had already
had a cocktail and I started I started
soft punching people's arms going oh we
got an idea who wants to make an idea
who wants a cocktail and then everyone
the first one when you break the first
card and he goes
okay I'm a bloody Mary and then
everyone's like I'm gonna take a Bloody
Mary
that makes the god
the world right you don't care about I
mean I love David Goggins I'm sure I'm
I'm just saying those guys that are
running 50 miles I'm sure there's a God
looking down that's a different kind of
drug that's another drug [__] yeah get
after it but I guarantee you as a God
you're like oh [__] oh [__] look at him
someone got laid last night they're all
sitting around the table shut the [__]
up they just woke up they got McDonald's
[__] Egg McMuffins they're about to
tell the story he's breaking out a
bottle of champagne yeah the [__] story
like that energy is so [__] fun dude
by something I love about being on a
tour bus is
is
that moment where like everyone's closed
their curtains but someone that you hear
someone open their curtain and and tell
something out the thing and everyone
just starts giggling and and those
moments are like the camp moments
remember Camp when you be a camper and
everyone would be trying to go to bed
and one guy's like there's Brian in here
he's like yeah he goes Tony's gay and
everyone just laughs it's like the
dumbest joke right yeah and then you go
does Brian have his Funk and he calls
mom I mean that energy and look it's
methead it's it's that [__] sense of
humor yeah is what would keep me it
would I would wake up if you think about
your life like you you measure your life
I guess partially in accomplishments but
what you really think about is the times
you laughed like what actually connects
you and what makes friends is the times
you were [__] yucking it up right
like think about it every time like that
that's kind of where connection is I
don't I don't have any memory of Joe
other than laughter that's what I mean
like like I have memories of Joe like
but like when people say Joe I use Joe's
examples we're all friends with but like
when people bring up Joe Rogan to me I
don't think about the Ivermectin or the
[__] okay I don't think of any of
this none of that [__] ever registered
to me it lands on me like a [__]
light balloon what I remember is one
time
he said he said to me
high as [__] he goes
how many think how many fish do you
think we'd still have if you threw a
fish 10 feet in the air and it could
start flying
I said not a lot I don't think and then
I went wait hold on if you go I mean if
you could go fishing and he goes yeah
yeah he caught a fish and then you throw
in there he goes how much would you
enjoy fishing I go I [__] love Yeah
but those moments where you giggle with
it yeah they're the best they're the
best moments you'll ever have yes I mean
the number one moment I think of with us
with the in Austin that aubry's
Penthouse and you and I smoked weed and
you there's all those girls there but
you're just trying to make me laugh so
hard we're on like the 12th Penthouse he
was laughing I almost fell off the side
of the [__] building
with her dog and I go your dog's got a
bum ticker huh Time to Say Goodbye to it
remember that I was killing you like
that and then the best was when that guy
came in with a wig and you were like no
no you got a hell of a hair you got a
hell of a set of hair on you hey this
guy comes in right it's this big deal
when we're just starting uh podcasting
this is like 12 years ago we're just
starting we're trying to get sponsored
for the podcast and I I guess in the
room with nutrition he's not there
anywhere nutrition it's a big deal it's
gonna be overall deal we're sitting down
we're talking I'm like where's the main
guy who gets the deals they're like
he'll come in a little bit so we're
talking he walks
bro his wig is a Pittsburgh Steelers
helmet yeah he didn't know because he
comes in he's a very handsome striking
man big guy all dressed up but so
clearly uh
no but he goes like this Brandon goes he
doesn't see it at first he goes we're
about to have the meeting he walks in
and he goes like this he goes and
Brendan I I clock immediately that's a
toupee be quiet Brandon goes guys got
quite the set of hair on him as in he's
complimenting and I go like this away
because we're here
and I'm telling you dude I was laughing
we couldn't do it
hey remember they go are you they go are
you two all right and I go yeah I'm
laughing at the doll over this no you
know when you can't stop laughing oh are
you kidding me that's my favorite times
of my [__] Chrome
it didn't happen
yes I go you got a set of hair on y'all
I swear to God the way guys hunt the way
guys fish I do that for Laughs yes I sit
with my bait in the water waiting for a
laugh that's right waiting for a laugh
and no I don't want to create it all
I've ever done I want to find it I want
to find it and if you can show me a
laugh I love that more than anything
yeah I did I did uh
I'm just saying this very casually
have you seen the kid that fell off
stage I saw you laugh about it I saw
your reaction to it I was like what was
your reaction
yeah
it's the funniest but that's the
funniest energy the energy of
when you can make me laugh like that you
got a special place in my heart yeah
like you for the rest of my life okay
Austin Black's his name
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's It's the
funniest it's the hardest time not the
hardest I've ever left the hardest I've
ever left the hardest I've ever laughed
Tom has made me the laugh three times
the hardest I've ever left without a
[__] doubt no it uh comic falls off
the stage the other Laugh Factory race
car from Chicago it's not L.A yeah this
[__] kid this makes me laugh
freaky Chicago girls and I've come to
the realization I've been talking to one
that I don't think pegging is
necessarily that yeah
it's always so good it's always so good
it's always it's good it's just this
Christmas
wait hold on can you access the true
Divinity the true Divinity that's right
is when you watch yourself laugh and you
laugh also no have you can you do that
well we were we were watching I shot him
at Louis CK clip that I can't play dude
I can't stop laughing what is it
I could not stop laughing I had to send
it [__] everybody I know but it's
because it's the idea of it's Louis show
the idea of him
for the recording of the show yeah
I don't even want to know anything
it's just about they're right there no
no no no no
it's gonna make your day
[Music]
why would they make it safer press the
dark button
listen
okay
everybody
she runs off she goes oh [__]
you couldn't do it
you can't do it now now you couldn't do
it the best way
s you could do it then
all right
[Applause]
away
okay
oh [__] man I laugh at it every time
one more time
this is there
[Applause]
a hamster
this is
watch her run off
[Music]
thank you
why would they have that there why would
they have that there why would they have
that thing do you follow words
can they give you anymore
okay
oh [__] [__] [__] I am proud I am proud
to call Louis CK my friend I am proud to
call Lucy okay my friend that is the
heart why look man Hey listen if you're
my daughter Georgia who's watching this
right now in college and your and you
and your friends are not laughing shout
out to them if you're not laughing first
of all number one we're gonna have a
conversation we need to have a
conversation but number three Georgia
but that is the [__] that is the
point of Comedy is the thing you don't
expect most outrageous thing the most
outrageous
in 1955
here's okay okay the Holy Grail of
Comedy the Holy Grail of Comedy oh I
don't know everything I'm just saying
this I'm just I'm spitballing right now
is when you can hear the thing that you
said again in your head you can hear you
say it for the first time yeah or
someone Taps you and you start laughing
again at the same level
but no but like like uh
I
can be pictured him recording that I'm
writing it is that something that's in
the museum or did he write that that's
the real question
oh [__] [__] me he wrote that
oh god dude I uh oh I'm sweating honey
it's not it was the button
I have a simpleton's access to Comedy in
that I love laughing and like and like
there's people that don't that don't
enjoy comedy they just don't and I think
they think they're comedy fans but they
don't enjoy it they don't really enjoy
it and the whole thing about comedy is
just like does it make you giggle and
and if it doesn't then it's not a fail
like a lot of [__] doesn't make you good
we're going to McDonald's doesn't make
you giggle you know but like the [__]
[Music]
is the funniest
human being I've ever met in my life
and she is only funny because she has
never tried to be funny and so the
things she says you hear it from her
perspective and you go what Jesus and
it's our it's our goal as Comics is to
get there is to the second you try to
look like you're trying to be funny it
it never works but the second that you
can access that angle of like
of like almost like either you're with
it or I don't know I don't know it's
really hard to achieve but man when
Brian said he couldn't do that today
I hope that anyone that watched any of
that I don't know how you're going to
edit that together
oh my God no we'll have we will have the
video on but to have our reaction on
[__] I'm gonna do my best to shopping
yeah you gotta chop it you got to figure
it out it probably was 2015. or
something it was actually pretty
accurate it was pretty close to now yeah
[__] that's what makes it what I'm
saying is that you would not have a
network that would allow that even to be
a joke
like yeah today there's not a shot that
would be fine no any kind of in the
writer's room oh they were not in a
million years no no God bless we lost
our mind around all that stuff somewhere
around uh after you know
like that in my life where you where you
can't stop and you hear the words that
people said in your head as you're as
you're laughing you hear them right you
hear them one of the best that's one of
the best by the way I can name them I
can name them we did the other day I can
name them I gave you a good laugh that's
one of the best laughs I've ever had
I'll take dude you have no idea you have
no idea how appreciative I am and I'll
tell you why and I mean this for real
one day I can watch this clip and I and
I what I mean I may need you to get that
whole clip and do that whole clip put it
up on YouTube by itself just whatever
what it is just for me because I know I
can access watching me laugh yeah laugh
again yeah I have that ability and I
know that that may be hacky or whatever
but I can giggle at funny moments well
that's like a Bobby Lee thing when he
was talking about being molested
and I watched that with he and I trying
to laugh yeah he goes if you laugh again
I'm gonna leave right now
oh it's one of the best dude you guys
have so many Great Clips like that I'm
doing this for 10 years
over 10 years I love one of my favorite
ones is I I saw it I saw it I saw it I
have no idea but I'm watching uh you and
Delia and you were talking about Drake
concert and you're like Drake concerts
are awesome and and it's Delia's
delivery and you go and he goes you went
to a direct concert because my brother
didn't go so that's a different person
right and you went yeah but like those
that that pacing of that is so [__]
good and you only get that you only get
that when you know people for that long
yeah that where you where your your
energy is positive and it's and it's but
it's also ball busty and it's also fun
and it's also like it's oh God that was
the whole point of that before they shut
the comedy store down that's what we all
did what Mr me and Dalia started doing
that whole ragging on each other back
when we were doing the [__] Laugh
Factory Jamie masado would be there Dove
David off Steve Byrne and we'd all be
sitting around that was an underrated
Talent one of the greatest I've said
this I've said this over and over again
he's opening for me this well is this
I'm doing Tony Hall and in New York City
and when you see this people have
already done it uh Sunny Hall in New
York City he's gonna he's coming he's
coming he's there so I go just come up
and just do 30 minutes or whatever
because he took time off because he made
all the money in real estate yeah he got
into real estate he's done a bunch of TV
shows too and then he's so [__] funny
I've done podcasts where all I did was
celebrate Dove I have a real affection
for dove because he's a he's a real dude
he's a real dude in so many ways I know
he's fighting like a mother one of my
favorite people in the world man I
[__] I I Adore that dude like in a
way because I when I started in New York
he he showed up around when I was
working the door at the Boston comedy
club and he was just
a different breed man when you go to
college like the way I went to college
for seven years you can recognize huge
like like dudes coming as freshmen
because I was in a fraternity and you
want to give them a bit immediately so
it's a I'm gonna I dare I say it's like
a gay attraction like when you you
recognize you want guys to be an
fraternity but you want them to be in
because you know they're cool you can
sense cool in other dudes it's a gay
thing it is a gay thing but you're like
this guy's a face guy he's gonna get
tons of [__] he'll bring tons of posts
a year let's get him here and I just
left uh Tallahassee when I moved to New
York and the second I'm at dub there's
two dudes I was like I was like that's
why I would rush I mean you know
dub David off to Nick Swardson you want
to hear it
made a speech at my wedding wasn't
supposed to I had my wedding and this is
15 years ago and and everybody's
speaking you know all my friends Jimmy
Burke hilarious my sister [__]
hilarious other friends hilarious not
this last one no this is my 15 years
yeah and Dove um at the height of his
powers and he wasn't does that
depressive Dove suffers from what he
calls the black black dog because I got
to touch the black dog you know he says
he has this joke you ever want to kill
somebody but you don't have the strength
to get off the couch you know it's that
kind of right yeah
and uh so this is in front of 200 people
at my wedding
and he gets up and he and he goes you
know
because all these people making jokes
you know and I wrote some [__] down but
uh you know I don't really know how to
be funny
you know but you know this guy
this guy he said you know it's weird how
people mean something to you you know
but you know Bertrand Russell
uh he was a British philosopher and he
didn't kill himself
and he said he didn't kill himself
because he wanted to learn more about
math
you know this guy
something happened to this guy man
I guess Brian's kind of like my math
Jesus Christ he just got and he goes
have a good night everybody and that was
his speech in my wedding oh wow
everybody just intense everybody just
went I was just like this I was just
looking at him going bad [__]
and all my friends came up and they go
that guy's really special I go yeah
that's Dove David
it was such a beautiful thing where Dove
broke up with his fiance because she
[__] in a hotel room
not in the hotel room
look I don't know about that Dove has a
tough as a thing you know he's got a
thing he's like she's beautiful I can't
imagine her [__] and then all of a
sudden she shouldn't 10 feet Bert your
wife does this and I go yeah everyone
does and Christina is a girl was like
yeah he [__] in front of Tom and he's
like in front of her in front of her you
should direct I go we all [__] in front
of him he's like I'm out of this I'm out
of this and he broke up with her when he
when he we were at The Comedy Store and
I apologize is that not is that that's
fine whatever we were about to leave
when he moved on he went to New York he
went to New York what do you name his
kid
um Brendan uh his son's name is Emerson
son his son's name is Emerson Emerson
Emerson
no no because that's where my head was
that too so you know we're too dumbass
Ruth after Ruth Bader Ginsburg yeah yeah
Dove is such a bad [__] he
really is I mean I I bums me out so I
met him when we were kids and then I I
reconnected a couple times where you'd
hang out with him and not a ton
obviously but uh he's made me giggle
consistently because he's he's I mean
this I hope you guys get what I'm about
to say yeah he's like Brody when you
can't tell
if it if you can't tell if there's a
character if you're trying to make you
laugh or if he's just being Dove get it
yeah and you go and you go yeah and
you're like he left LA because he
couldn't have a conversation we're a
communist tour and somebody comes up and
says hey man what's going on Douglas oh
Jesus Christ another guy and he goes
this [__] owl I'm talking to me this
[__] owl calls him an owl and then he
goes like this he goes I gotta go to New
York right he goes I go what he goes I
gotta leave you I go what do you mean he
goes I can't do it anymore bro and he
just left and I remember when we first
doing fire kid live and we did the
gramsley theater around New York and
then that night we hung out with Dove
and he was doing a spot at the in the
cellar and I went down and watched him
and I was like holy yeah man I just
remember watching me like holy yeah yeah
he's he's man he's an original [__] I
was like oh man I'm so smart he's an
original all right man I've I've sung
this to the to the to the heavens he's
an original talent for real top to
bottom original talent and I say that to
anyone not listening I don't think you
can find even content of Dove really
like it's it's we've had my final kid
back I can't get him to do any promotion
or anything he didn't give a [__] and
that's and that's when you go that's
what's cool that's kind of what's cool
it's like but you're not selling tickets
well no it's cool though no but but he
didn't need to I think if I'm not
mistaken I'm gonna say that Patel
doesn't even have to go where do I have
to go I was trying to make oh yeah I got
a dinner with my parents pretty soon but
don't worry hold on hold on hold on hold
on parents can wait the thing about bub
is he uh just kidding dude good job he
I remember him saying he grew up with
David Lee Roth
well no no that's not what so Dove owned
a
building's father died that's it that's
it they owned they owned a junkyard a
junkyard where they sold scrap metal so
Dove's dad dad used to [__] the dude
well don't worry
are those stories his father died of
AIDS okay okay so his father died of
AIDS but but Dove's dad left him some
the junkyard with you know his his
brother and stuff so Dove is down the
Lower East Side now just so you guys
know in New York before when Lower East
Side now like Rivington Street and all
that it's nice now you couldn't I had to
be my buddy John Joseph used to have to
meet me at at Houston to walk me down
where past cat's Deli that area you
could go there you couldn't go there
yeah it would literally side back then
Puerto Rican gangs when I was doing
stand up in 1998 it was it was sketchy
Dawson grew up so bubba this is 1982 93
94 oh that's even worse and by the way I
was down there and
so you couldn't
I was in college
my bad my bad my bad my bad you couldn't
go down there if you didn't have a few
and it was for real dangerous for real
real dangerous
so doves down there
and he he's down there in the 90s and he
starts seeing he goes I saw some gay
dudes
just Milling about he's gay I saw a
bunch of gay dudes and then one guy
opened a muffin shop and I see these gay
guys eating muffins
I see it I see a couple gay guys eating
a couple muffins he's so New York and I
think to myself
this place is on the up and up
so he gets a [__] bag of of cash I
won't say how much
and he goes and he buys the building
from this Chinese Triad dude and just
gives him the cash and the guy writes
him a [__] Deed now he owns the
building
and sure enough it's on Rivington and
Ludlow right now you couldn't buy that
building for [__] unders I've also
done Brownsville correct I don't know
how much how much like now you that
building would cost you 20 million 30
million yeah so so he buys some David
Lee Roth we own he lives in the bottom
floor David Lee Roth start rents the top
part so the first time I come over to
his house he goes hey hey Dove and he
goes hey Diamond he called him Diamond
Dave and I look up and I go
are you David Lee Roth
uh he was the lead singer of a band
called Van Halen uh sidebar sidebar
sidebar sidebar yeah yeah
first night I'm in New York I've been
written up in Rolling Stone magazine is
the number one part of them in the
country I moved to New York I started
I'm hoping to start stand up I end up at
a bar called Mary Lou's at three in the
morning and bars are closing and I'm
down there and a dude hits me up punches
me in the arm with a beautiful check
uh and he goes oh [__] you're the party
animal and I was like yeah and he was
like oh I just read your article Rolling
Stone magazine on the plane I was like
oh thanks man I'm trying to keep like
the low-key so I appreciate it thank you
very much he's like no no no
no Harvey Abel check this guy out
and I was like I was like hey man I'm
trying to like hang out with this chick
I really appreciate it and then the
chick I look at the chick and she goes
David Lee Roth knows who you are I look
over at David Lee Roth I go shut the
[__] up it's Abel Ferrara and Harvey
Keitel oh my God calm down and I might
stop
Mary Lou's on 13th wow dude my first
night in Ella oh my God I know Harvey a
little bit I don't know I don't know
that's pretty [__] cool that's like
yeah it was the coolest [__] moment
to have when you get sadly I didn't know
who Abel or Hari Harvey was Ferrari did
King of New York one of my favorite
movies of all time with Christopher
Walken I didn't know who he was so well
there's no reason you would have known
him yeah but he looks like The Walking
Dead oh wow yeah they were all at the
end of the bar but he was something else
would he do hell of a film writer and
director is he a white walker uh he he
definitely he definitely has had he's
lived a hard life
no nothing
older ones
I'll ask you no no no no no no no no no
that's that's me and Christy Mack
what would you do with Christy Mack I
just uh hung out with her really to be
honest with you yeah she's pretty cool
how's she doing she's doing great she's
not doing porn man looks good in that
way yeah
I love my wife you shouldn't hate that
dude that's great I'd love to be a dog
[__]
yeah no that's when we were children
yeah look at that look at that go to
that go to that that's right you look
like a crypto King she's so cute dude
she's so cute your wife is so cute
that's so much adorable yeah yeah butt
noses
she's cute as [__] pull her up in 52. I
don't know I'm joking I'm hammered she's
a cutie
all right we gotta get you out of here
no no no no hold on hold on hold on I'm
not done uh it's Leanne I know yeah yeah
yeah yeah just type in Leanne Chrysler
that's Dad look at you guys
um
tell me one here uh what's the normal
picture of her
I'm attracted to her so she's a cute
lady man I can't look at these pictures
of my kids like this no don't hurt
strong
they're old now and this is gonna happen
I can't imagine Brian it's happening to
you right now but I have a baby with one
I want one so bad I have a 14 month old
I race home would just get me someone
pregnant like let me get someone
pregnant I race home to my baby like I
race home to that oh nothing I'll show
you are you can I ask you a real
question and don't don't think don't
think just answer
is it more fun with the new one than the
old ones I'm not answering that question
it is you want me to answer the answer I
know I know
you know what you [__] because you had a
hunger in you when I had George and I
had a hunger in me that was insatiable
about succeeding and I knew that if I
didn't succeed and they weren't too much
yeah I was gone way too much I was gone
too much and I'm still heartburned yeah
but yeah but I understand but we have
[__] [__] to do people but you didn't
get divided now I've already burned the
bridge
you didn't get divorced yeah I did I
didn't and that [__] with me a lot well
now this guy I'm not no I'm not saying
I'm not saying I'm very very I love my
wife and I love my baby and I love my
kids and I get along great with my ex
but you you don't live down the fact
that you you failed yeah yeah you know
and it's okay but I mean well but but
failures on a swinging scale no no I'm
very happy with it
there's a there's an acknowledgment in
like and like this isn't working we're
gonna move that's great yep the the
problem I have is that it works with it
works with me and Leanne have you guys
ever been close to divorce no not even
remotely God bless you dude I'm I've
been with six chicks in my life like I
have nothing yeah I've no I don't I have
intimacy issues I have OCD problems like
I'm a [__] nightmare yeah and she
accepts me I'm cool yeah as long as
she's on the one yeah I found the one I
found the one yeah I found the one here
can I tell you I think about sliding
doors that Gwyneth Paltrow movie yeah
I've never seen it it's
right Gwyneth Paltrow I love that I love
did you say horror
passion I'd be down I just want to watch
a movie sliding doors I read the book
the uh
so but I think about like so I've been
offered as strip clubs like I go to
strip clubs all the time no no big deal
and
chicks have have like propositioned
themselves to me of course
I didn't realize that I'm now I've
always been burnt now you're moving now
I'm more famous and so it's happened and
so I had to
say no the easy things to say no for me
because I know that my life's very happy
I'm very happy and I know that if I do
something like that all that happiness
goes away my wife is also your best
friend right yeah hardcore yeah but I
want to really [__] other people that's
a dove quote that's actually a Rogan
quote long time ago yeah
um that's just in the Bible keep going
yeah the thing I think about a lot is
you think of
dudes who don't have that happiness like
I have no question about Leanne had I
not married Leanne I wouldn't be here
with you guys today promoting my Netflix
special Razzle Dazzle where she lets me
talk total [__] to her about her top to
bottom and my kids and we're all very
very happy George is in college the
girls are happy like everything's
[__] great I have no question about
my path in life because I found that
chick right I think a lot about the dude
who didn't find the right chick and his
life isn't going the right way and
sometimes you can blame it on that chick
I have nothing the reason I don't cheat
on my wife is that I have nothing but to
accredit my wife with my success because
I found the right chick and I'm the
happiest dude in the world yeah so like
it's like part of me goes like I think
maybe the most important decision you
make is who you choose to marry oh my
God oh my God oh my God I used to think
it was like what you do with your life I
think the most important decision you
make is who you choose I think it's two
things what you decide doing your life
and then Alpha also if you have someone
that Champions that and it makes the
home a home I think I think
accommodation I think I I could I'll
tell you right now by the way I could be
married to Leanne
MB
uh offense Builder
like I think about building fences a lot
does that go promo yeah
well I just know that those guys don't
take their work home with them like they
just build the fence yeah the thing
about painting the fences I think that I
think that what we do is is that we make
our living off our imagination and our
lives so there's no in our own bodies
and there's no time off because like
it's impossible for me anyway to write
funny [__] and surprise people and
surprise myself with my comedy and and
be uh civilian yeah I can't shut up you
can't clock out of him
be contractors or or or home builders or
cabinet makers yeah who can just shut it
off I do envy that and it's cool to make
art and make your thing and and put it
out
um
and I think if I was married to Leanne I
could probably do anything because I
would enjoy it because there's something
about her [__] giggle I look I don't
like celebrating my wife because it
seems like it seems [__] you know
like it seems [__] it doesn't to me
but but like a little bit like her
giggle it does seem [__] I I think
it does I resonate that's [__] is uh
when she like Giggles in the morning or
if she [__] with me it's your soul to
me dude I get a kick out of her I get a
kick out of the woman yeah and she
raised my daughters I did not I was on
the road I was I was barely there and
those two [__] [__] with me too and
they [__] with me hard as [__] do they
hold do they hold some resentment for
not being there for birthday parties God
look that's what they know his daughter
yeah they don't have a resentment for
him being a neighbor because Michael
Jordan's kid get mad at him that's the
thing about being a stand-up comic it's
like the
it's a really a weird way to make a
living
fraternity let me show you this this is
this is
full [__] I'm gonna piss hard after
this podcast yeah so
well so Georgia
uh junior and I don't know whatever
she's 16. I don't [__] that one
Junior
does it matter yeah uh did Georgia go to
a good school yeah yeah I like her
school a lot I'll tell you all fair yeah
please
um so good sports teams let's just talk
about it off air let's talk about it's
not fair yeah man shut up so uh yeah
so uh they there's a bit in the special
my special Razzle Dazzle is is airing
right now on Netflix
and the girls call me baby walrus right
but this is it's it's ball busters I
love ball busting [__] I love it
there's no better woman to hang out with
than a woman that can punch in the dick
verbally and then
and so today Georgia sent me this text
she goes I miss this guy and that's a
picture of me as baby walrus oh that's
funny and it's and but if you watch the
the clip of me doing it I look like a
[__] walrus that's so cute and so I
love that that's who she raised I didn't
raise those chicks like Leanne did but I
love that I'm drunk now let's get me the
[__] out God bless everybody
his movies
this has been a [__]
I almost passed out uh please send me
the clip of us laughing like that please
do even if I'll I don't care I'll take
the [__] strike I'll put it on mine
whatever it's so good tops off World
Tour uh Bismarck whatever Sioux Falls
Oshkosh Peoria Rockford Augusta sell it
all out uh this comes out next so I'm in
Tacoma uh March 23rd through the 25th
all right chin here we go [__] yeah I'm
not that drunk March 23rd through 25th
Tacoma Washington Atlanta Georgia
Spokane's coming up Belfast I'm headed
to Europe so June 15th you're about fast
Belfast hold on Belfast Ireland yeah oh
dude shout out to my uh whose podcast
are you doing when you're up there
probably uh true Jordi that's who I
hooked you up with yeah true jordy's
there he's in line right but there's a
great Belfast podcast up there I'll set
you up yeah set me up yeah yeah yeah so
it's Belfast Glasgow Manchester what
else is it uh London Cardiff Dublin
that's coming up in June it's June 17th
through the 25th get your chicken thick
boy.com I'll see you guys at West Nyack
New York Levity Live uh this coming
weekend fight campaign Joe Rogan's on
Jerry the lives on uh Rogan's YouTube
then it goes to Spotify that's for uh
Leon Edwards versus Usman it's me Rogan
Eddie Bravo myself a special guest love
you guys Bert we [__] love you go
watch this special Razzle Dazzle on
Netflix streaming right now
Razzle Dazzle